so right now nearly 1 billion people
globally don't have access to
electricity in their homes and in South
China Africa more than half of the
population remain in the dark so you
probably all know this image from NASA
there's a name for this darkness it's
called energy poverty and it has massive
implications for economic development
and social well-being one unique aspect
of the energy poverty problem in
sub-saharan Africa and by the way in
this talk when I say energy
I mean electricity wanting what's unique
about it is there isn't much legacy
infrastructure already in place and much
in many countries of the region so for
example according to 2015 data the total
installed electricity capacity in South
Side Africa is only about a hundred to
go out that's similar to that of the UK
so this actually presents a unique
opportunity to build an energy system in
the 21st century almost from scratch
question is how do you do that we could
look back to the past and replicate the
ways in which we've managed to bring
stable affordable electricity to a big
part of the world's population but we
all know that that has some well-known
terrible side effects such as pollution
and climate change in addition to being
costly and inefficient with Africa's
population set to quadruple by the end
of the century
this is not a theoretical question
Africa needs a lot of energy and it
needs it fast because it's population is
booming and its economy needs to develop
so for most countries the general
trajectory of electrification has been
as follows first large-scale Grid
infrastructure is put in place usually
with significant public investment that
infrastructure then powers productive
centers such as factories agricultural
mechanization commercial commercial
enterprises and the like and this sense
stimulates economic growth creating jobs
raising incomes and producing a virtuous
cycle that helps more people afford more
appliances which then creates
residential
demand for electricity but in subsonic
ax despite decades of energy projects we
haven't really seen these benefits the
energy projects have often been
characterized by waste corruption and
inefficiency our rural electrification
rates are really low and our urban rates
could be better the reliability of our
electricity is terrible and we have some
of the highest electricity prices in the
whole world and on top of all of this
we're now facing the impacts of the
gorian climatic catastrophe head-on so
Africa will need to find a different
path and as it turns out we're now
witnessing some pretty exciting
disruption in the African energy space
this new path is called
off-grid solar and it's enabled by cheap
solar panels advances in LED and battery
technology and combined with innovative
business models so these off-grid solar
products typically range from a single
light to home system kits that can
charge phones power television or on a
fan I want to be clear off-grid solar is
a big deal in Africa I have worked in
the sector for years and these products
are enabling us to extend basic energy
services to some of the world's poorest
raising their quality of life this is a
very good and a very important thing
however off-grid solar will not solve
energy poverty in Africa and for that
matter neither will a top-down effort to
connect every unserved household to the
grid see I'm not here to rehash that
played out on versus off-grid or old vs.
new debate instead I believe that our
inability to grapple with and truly
address energy poverty in Africa stems
from three main sources first we don't
really have a clear understanding of
what energy poverty is or how deep it
goes
second we're avoiding complex systemic
issues and prefer quick fixes and third
we are misdirecting concerns about
climate change combined these three
mistakes are leading us to impose a
Western debate on the future of energy
and falling back on paternalistic
attitudes towards Africa so let me try
and unpack these three questions first
what exactly is energy poverty the main
energy poverty target and indicator
enshrined in the UN seven sustainable
development goal or SDG seven it calls
for a hundred percent of the world's
population to have access to electricity
by the year 2030
this binary threshold however ignores
the quality reliability or utility of
the power the indicators are currently
being developed that will try and
capture these things however the
question of when a household is
considered connected is not quite clear
cut so for example last year the Indian
Prime Minister Narendra Modi declared
all of the villages in India electrified
the criteria for electrification being a
transformer in every village plus it's
public centers and ten percent ten
percent of US households connected
meanwhile the International Energy
Agency which tracks progress against SD
g7 defines energy access as 50 kilowatt
hours per person per year that's enough
to power some light bulbs and charge a
phone perhaps run Aloha
TV or fan for a few hours a day now
providing entry level access is an
important first step
but let's not romanticize the situation
by any standard a few lights and not
much else is still living in energy
poverty and what's more these energy
poverty indicators and targets cover
only residential use and yet households
account for just about 1/4 of the
world's electricity consumption that's
because most of our power is used in
industries and for commerce which brings
me to my main point countries cannot
grow out of poverty without access to
abundant affordable and reliable
electricity to power these productive
centers or what I call energy for growth
as you can see from this graph
they simply no such thing as a low
energy high income country doesn't exist
and yet three billion people in the
world currently live in countries
without reliable affordable electricity
not just to power their homes but also
their factories their office buildings
their data centers and other economic
activities nearly electrifying
households and micro enterprises cannot
solve these deeper energy poverty to
solve energy poverty we need to deliver
reliable affordable electric
city at scale to deliver to power
economy-wide job creation and income
growth this need however bumps against
an emerging narrative that face with
climate change we all need to transition
from large centralized power systems to
small-scale distributed power the growth
of off-grid solar in Africa and let me
repeat off khatola is a good thing but
that growth fits nicely into this
narrative and has led to those claims
that Africa is leapfrogging the old ways
of energy and building its power system
from the ground up one solar panel at a
time it's a nice solicitous narrative
but also quite naive like many
narratives of technological disruption
often inspired by Silicon Valley it
takes for granted the existing systems
that underpin all of this transformation
you see when it comes to innovating in
energy the West is working around the
edges of a system that is tried and
tested and so all the sexy stuff the
rooftop solar the smart the smart
household devices the electric vehicles
all of this is built on top of a massive
and absolutely essential grid which
itself exists within a proven governance
framework even the most advanced
countries in the world don't have an
example of an energy system that is all
edges and no centered scale so
ultimately no approach be it centralized
or distributed renewable a fossil based
consol can succeed in solving energy
poverty without finding a way to deliver
reliable affordable electricity to
Africa's emerging industrial and
commercial sectors so it's not just
lights in every rural home its power for
Africa cities that are growing fast and
increasingly full of young capable
people in desperate need of a job this
in turn will require significant
interconnectivity and economies of scale
making our robust and modern grid a
crucial piece of any energy poverty
solution so our second mistake is
falling for their lure of the quick fix
you see energy poverty exists within a
complex socio-economic and political
context and part of the appeal of
new electrification models such as
off-grid solar for example is they can
often bypassed a glacial pace and an
efficiency of government C with small
systems you can skip that you can skip
the bureaucracies and the utilities and
sell directly to customers but to
confront energy poverty you cannot
ignore governments you cannot ignore
institutions you cannot ignore the many
players involved in making moving and
using electricity at scale which is a
way to say that when it comes to
providing energy for growth it's not
just about innovating the technology
it's about the slow and hard work of
improving governance institutions and
the broader macro environment ok so this
is all good and nice you say but what
about climate change how do we ensure a
high energy future for everyone while
also carving our emissions well we'll
have to make some complex trade-offs but
I believe that a higher energy future
for Africa is not mutually exclusive to
a low-carbon future and make no mistake
the world cannot expect Africa to remain
in energy poverty because of climate
change
[Music]
actually the facts show that the
opposite is true energy will be
essential for Africa to adapt to climate
change and build resilience you see
rising temperatures will mean increased
demand for space cooling and cold
storage declining water tables will mean
increased Pumped irrigation and extreme
weather and rising sea levels will
require a significant expansion and
reinforcement of our infrastructure
these are all energy intensive
activities so balancing climate change
and Africa's pressing need to transition
to a high energy future will be tough
but doing so is non-negotiable we will
have to find a way the first step is
broadening the terms of the debate away
from this either-or framing and we also
must stop romanticizing solutions that
distract us from the core challenges and
let's not also forget that Africa is
endowed with vast natural resources
including significant renewable
potential for example in Kenya where I'm
from geothermal power accounts for half
of our electricity generation and with
hydro being the other major source we
already mainly powered by renewable
energy we also just brought online
Africa's largest wind farm and East
Africa's bigger solar facility in
addition new technology means that we
can now run and design our power systems
and use energy more efficiently than
ever doing more with less energy
efficiency will be an important tool in
the fight against climate change so in
closing I just like to say that Africa
is a real place with real people
navigating complex challenges and major
transitions just like any other region
of the world
and well each country and each region
has its social economic and political
quirks the physics of electricity are
the same everywhere
and the energy needs of our economies
are just as intensive as those of any
other any other economy so the expansion
of household electrification through a
mix of on and off grid solutions has had
an incredible impact in Africa but
they're nowhere near sufficient for
solving energy poverty to solve energy
poverty we need generation of
electricity from diverse sources at
scale and modern grids to power a high
energy future in which Africans can
enjoy modern living standards and
well-paying jobs
Africans deserve this and with one of
every four people in the world projected
to be african by the year 2100 the
planet needs it thank you
[Applause]